I do not say bleh bleh-bleh well here's
a movie I didn't think I was gonna talk
about but I've seen it so let's talk
about it
Hotel Transylvania 3 a series that I
have not talked about on the show up to
this point I haven't I didn't see any of
the films in the theater I saw the first
one my daughter likes this franchise
this is why I saw the third one so I saw
the first one the first five minutes of
the first one are painful for someone
who has never even oh I when I was young
really loved bathroom human humour the
first five minutes of that first movie
our total overload of it after that it
settles into a pretty decent rhythm the
second one I haven't seen it's entirely
but I've seen bits and pieces of it
works pretty well I went into this third
one with a definite sense of dread I
mean it's just it's just taking the
characters taking them on a boat like
that that's it that's the worst kind of
you know contrived nonsense for a sequel
like why not I saw it I'm like it's
pretty good it's not great now that I'd
like I don't want to oversell this but I
am ultimately going to be pointing out a
heck of a lot more good things than bad
things first off if you're like me and
you you are iffy about the toilet humor
there's basically only one fart joke and
it's kind of cute so there's that I I
will always love genndy tartakovsky
'he's the directors sense of physicality
because the the man very much makes
cartoons and I know that's like book not
not all animation is cartoons at least
the way that he sort of does them
because he harkens back to an older
style of an older Looney Toons early
Disney Max Fleischer kind of style with
wit characters with really bendy bodies
and you know that the head will lock in
place but the body like will do laps
around while the next stretches and does
all this weird stuff
and it it's difficult to do right and he
does he does it very well and I think
it's because he understands to not
bombard with the high-energy non-stop he
knows when to slow down he knows when to
take a quieter moment he knows how to
pace it so it's not just an assault of
high energy and noise and in feeling
like a DD the movie it's not it feels
like we get the appropriate breathers at
the appropriate time and the the man's
got a great sense of comic timing and
it's actually quite impressive how well
he's able to execute these movies and
these concepts and these ideas and it it
does have a very predictable story I'm
not gonna get into spoilers but it's
kind of hard to spoil but I again I say
that as an adult I suspect to the target
audience most kids will not figure the
entire plot out within the first 10
minutes which I did but again it's not a
movie aimed at me and that's the thing
like most of the things that I would
normally have criticized a film like
this for I don't feel are fair
criticisms of this film and it's very
rare for me to say that well I don't
like to give passes for things just
because they're a genre that isn't held
to the same high standard but like I
said the man makes cartoons he's not
making Pixar films Disney films he's not
doing any of those kinds of things what
he what this director makes is a cartoon
and you need to judge it more by the
measure of like comparing it to
something like the Looney Tunes shorts
as opposed to your standard
feature-length animation of today that
is more realistic that just does almost
none of what this film does not when
you're dealing in live-action like for
one thing and you especially don't see
this very often in CGI animated films
physics go out the window
I mean that that's often one of the big
things with CGI 3d animation
is that you have to get the physics to
behave themselves and this thing is no
use for for real-world physics to heck
with it and you know things that I would
normally criticize like the fact that
there is a decent core story but all the
ancillary characters are just there
because they've been there in the past
and they are given almost nothing to do
except show up and kill a bit of time
every now and then
normally I criticize the film for that
but I watched this and I go well the
core story wasn't going to fill 90
minutes and we can get just little
snippets of these other characters and
they are in the same high energy vein
little jokes that the rest of the film
is and because that's what this film
does it works and the I mean the voice
cast has always been solid on this and I
say this is somebody who does not like
Adam Sandler it's never like that I'm
Sandler but it helps a lot when I'm not
looking at his face but it said just
hearing his voice come out of a
character who is really well animated
and really lively and works very well
and same with the the rest of the cast
and you know there are something you can
say because say for instance Mel Brooks
returns as Dracula's father and you
could say that you know he's wasted he
has almost nothing to do but like I said
most of the supporting cast does it have
much to do except to get one off jokes
here and they're really the only ones
who get substantive stories is Dracula
his daughter Mavis and then a new
character who I don't want to really
talk about her mention cuz again they
kind of qualifies as spoilers insofar as
the that this film can be spoiled but
you know that's your core story and
everything else is just moments to break
from that which it needs and yeah it's
it's it's a solid three out of five star
you know 6 out of 10 kind of movie
nothing really wrong with it kind of
breezy kind of fun disposable but has
some good moments my daughter liked it a
lot
and that's the other thing I think this
will play really well too
to the target audience you know I I'm
thinking about I I kind of I gave this
like a number score in a star rating
don't get used to that that's not gonna
be standard like I guess I don't have
like a firm thing like that
like even in my head so I kind of wish I
didn't do that hadn't done that but I'm
probably too lazy to cut it out so what
are you gonna do I could cut it out but
cuz I'm lazy so it it works for the age
group but even you know speaking as a
parent it didn't hurt I liked that a
heck of a lot better than say Despicable
Me 3 which just felt like it was
absolutely scraping the bottom of the
barrel this actually feels like about as
organic a progressive progression of the
story for these characters was going to
be because it could very easily run into
what I consider to be the Shrek or the
Meet the Parents Meet the Fockers
franchise problems which is that because
the heart of the first one or two films
is the tension between characters who
are meant to come to terms with each
other by the end of it they keep having
contrived reasons to set that back to
zero for later films and usually by the
third one it's really painful and really
contrived and that's not as much the
case here even though we're still
focusing quite a bit on things that are
causing tension between Dracula and his
daughter Mavis at the same time they're
finding scenarios that don't feel as
contrived as these things usually do
it's a little contrived but it's not it
doesn't feel as regressive it doesn't
feel as a retrograde as these kinds of
moves do and that's just this admittedly
probably just made because the there's
still money potential in the name and
it's made to cash in on whatever
goodwill is left it's better than it
needed to be for what it is for what it
was designed to be and
and I can admire it for that even while
acknowledging that this is no great work
and I do not expect to this to show up
again when I do my top 10 at the end of
the year but it's good it's fun solid so
Hotel Transylvania 3 have you seen it
what did you think about it if you
haven't seen it what are your thoughts
on any of the films in the Hotel
Transylvania series so whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
that stuff to do that everybody on
YouTube does I do have a patreon page
links for that and all the other stuff
that we all do it's all down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]